we have this story from cnr.com Dana
White explains free speech to reporter
quote free speech Brother people can say
whatever they want and they can believe
whatever they want so following the
fight with uh sha Strickland and dricus
dupi Sean uh uh Shawn had made several
statements in the past about trans
people and you know uh people who have
who have gay kids and things like that
he mostly called a reporter a weak man
who was the enemy
he said that he was there to stand up
for the people of Canada F Trudeau
during the fight people were chanting F
tro Joe Rogan said Canada get your is
together man but I love I love the UFC
fan base I love the fighters we saw
Donald Trump come out at a UFC event
Madison Square Garden with Kid Rock and
Tucker Carlson the whole crowd of in New
York City screaming and cheering for
these individuals it's beautiful and so
I'm seeing this stuff and I'm thinking
you know I've never been super big on
UFC stuff but with these guys willing to
stand up for what they believe in for
the fans willing to stand up for what
they believe in I'm getting excited for
this so Dana White comes out and they
ask him this uh reporter says you
obviously give a Long Leash to your
Fighters about what they can say when
they are up there with the UFC
microphone Dana leash snaps back saying
I don't give a leash to anybody they can
say whatever they want now this is a
sport I like yeah I love that that's
fantastic and then you get Shan
Strickland who was the champ I say was I
think he still is and you have this
split decision after the fight where
they claim he lost the title and so this
is uh generating quite a bit of
controversy there's a lot of people
saying grow up stop being a whiny little
he lost but I I I I I I'll just
put it this way and then we can talk
about it there's a conspiracy theory of
course people are going to suggest this
that the reason Strickland was uh lost
was not because he was was the worst
fighter but because he's causing
problems for the brand so when people
say to Dana White you give your Fighters
a Long Leash and then he says I don't
give anybody a leash Dana White actually
said publicly he thought Strickland won
the fight but there are people saying on
Twitter and I don't blame him they're
saying that when budlight comes and
sponsors UFC and one of the Champs
starts ragging on Bud Light and putting
serious pressure on them there's going
to be pressure to get him out if they
can to end the quotequote era of
Strickland I don't know that I believe
that all I can say is this I'm not a big
UFC guy I don't know or care about
points and scoring I I I get it exists
all I can say is I get really excited
when you know we've had Colby Covington
here in the studio it was awesome to
meet this guy someone willing to stand
up for Trump publicly with no fear
because these Fighters have balls and
for sha Strickland to defend the people
of Canada wearing a make Canada great
against shirt I I tremendously love and
respect the defense of the working
people by people in these positions who
can speak up and have have influence so
I say wow I got to watch this I want I
want to see this guy fight he's the
champ I watch a fight I watch a guy win
a fight I watch them claim the other guy
won the fight I don't get it I mean I
understand why they're claiming he lost
I think it's the stupidest thing ever
and it makes me feel like it's all
fake I don't know I didn't see the fight
you said he got knocked down five times
no Strickland there were six takedowns
but uh
I I'll put it this way if if if I see
two guys fighting in the street it's
like the average person looks at that
and says like oh man that guy's beating
that guy up that's basically what
happened here Strickland was beating the
other guy up and then in the end they
were like yeah well you know he got
knocked down a handful of times and so
the judges thought it went the other way
so we're g him that the they guy the
fight so the Supreme Court of MMA has
ruled I got to tell you I went to the
UFC fight with Donald Trump in Las Vegas
uh several months ago it was an
extraordinary experience first of all
never has there been this much
testosterone in one Hall any place in
the country I mean it was it was an
allamerican extravagan nobody was nobody
was snacking on tofu if you know what I
mean and the the reaction that Trump got
was extraordinary just extraordinary now
I'm a big fan of Co of kobby Covington
I'm still I still haven't gotten over
the fact that he lost but you know what
he'll be back his greatest victories lie
ahead that guy's got guts and I'm
absolutely convinced that he comes back
I completely agree uh that was another
one of these fights so with with
Colby I was thinking he may actually
have taken in the last round but again
like I don't know I'm like for me I
watched that fight and I'm like honestly
I have no idea in the end he like the
final round Colby absolutely you know I
think he won that final round and then
he said he thought he won the fight too
watching the Strickland fight I just
that guy won a fight I feel like this is
the kind of thing that Strickland will
just be like and now I'm more motivated
than ever to do anything I can to to be
victorious I mean I've only heard him
interviewed a couple times I haven't
watched UFC consistently in years but uh
he's a really tenacious person and he is
very uh he's a very strong sense of self
and I think that really drives his
desire to compete and I think that's
actually why so many people like him
like yes his takes are kind of
interesting and what you expect but more
than anything he is a person of intense
conviction but as for uh I really like
and Trust Dana White so I there's no way
in the world he would wire a fight I I
never I never understood their you know
their scoring system I saw the same
fight you did I thought Strickland won
but what do I know I'm not one of the
judges look at this all that matters is
uh uh Joe Rogan he apparently agrees so
I defer to him and if Dana White also
the story from MMA junkie Joe Rogan
surprised judges awarded dricus dupi win
over Shan Strickland it's an amazing
clip I watched it Rogan normally is
commentating on these fights and uh when
the when the ruling came down he says
wow
interesting very interesting I wonder
how the people online feel about that
cuz we're not scoring it while we're
watching it we're just having fun were
we wrong that's exactly how I felt when
I watched this I I I'm like dude I
bought this pay-per-view thing I'm super
excited to support Sean Strickland he's
he's he's standing up for the little guy
it's exactly what we want to see in
these Sports I watch a fight I watch
this guy win it was close dupi is
amazing it was a really awesome fight uh
Strickland his eyes covered in blood it
was it was good and then they're just
like nah he loses and I'm like what man
so I don't know dude I'm just I don't
understand it I guess we have this uh
from verdict mma.com a lot of people
were sending me where you've got a
couple different metrics by which the
fight was judged and scored and it looks
like the Med like like media uh uh
scored it for for Strickland but the
judges went the other direction on it so
it is what it is man I don't think it
was a I I don't believe that it was
rigged in the sense that like Dana White
had anything to do with it Dana White
publicly stated he thought Strickland
won too yeah that indicates there's
going to be a
rematch they're going to create some uh
animosity between the two fighters the
box office on that yes so I say I say
Shenanigans it sucks whatever he got
robbed people are like he didn't get
robbed he just lost I'm like that's what
it means like it was a close fight we
get that they gave to the other guy he
was robbed meaning it should have
slightly gone the other direction but a
rematch could be really good in that
everything Strickland got to say will be
Amplified tenfold when we start building
up to a potential rematch which I really
hope happens yeah I was thinking about
the uh bread and circus they say in
failing Empires they the Empire gives
its citizens bread and circus in order
to keep them distracted and fed so they
don't Riot and then they just and so
this is the circus aspect but the
difference is that we've got Mass media
and internet video like Sean Strickland
can make a video and like alter the
minds of the masses in a day that I
don't the Romans didn't have the
Gladiators didn't have that kind of
influence on society or their own
Instagram Pages where they can post
Clips or them working out or I mean like
people become really devoted to a lot of
athletes but definitely UFC athletes who
are just like they personify something
they aspire to be right they're tough
they're strong they're con they're like
Peak physical fitness and this is a day
and age where you can feel like a
personal relationship to these athletes
in a way that you never have before it's
crazy when we had Colby Covington on I
had a lot of people being like Oh man
cuz he's such a wild guy and then he
shows up and he's the nicest most polite
honorable guy and you people need to
understand that right that he he's out
there he's he's he's being a personality
but he's he's a good regular dude he
knows what he's doing he's a smart guy
he's he's I'm a big fan and it was
really awesome to get to meet him but I
appreciate when you know I see all the
time
let me put it this way why I like UFC so
much I've been skateboarding my whole
life I was skateboarding earlier today
tried to do a kick flip pivot slipped
out it was fun didn't land it all these
pro skateboarders will hit me up being
like I'm a big fan of your show man but
I can't say anything because I'll I'll
get fired or whatever I'm so scared and
I'm like man it's like these guys who
jump off buildings for a living their
balls dropped off and then I see kobby
Covington and Strickland and I'm like
these guys will shut to the High Heavens
F you I'll say whatever I feel like
saying now that inspires me and I'm like
these guys are great so I like what UFC
is doing as you mentioned more
testosterone what do you say it's the
most testost I've ever seen in one place
at one time I'm looking forward to
seeing more of these guys yeah but
cultural victories I guess right the
fact that uh Trump can walk out in a
urban Democrat stronghold and have the
whole crowd cheering for him this is you
know it was pandemonium it wasn't just
cheering the play he Che the place
upside down it was absolute earsplitting
pandemonium that's awesome I think he's
the most famous guy on Earth right now
he is yeah well and people I mean look
I've known him a long time I'm not
allowed to say how old because he says
it makes us both sound old but the guy's
energy level is just extraordinary I
mean he he's he always required very
little sleep but through all of this and
I talked to him Sunday he's
upbeat he he's res he's determined he's
extraordinarily confident uh he's in a
great mood uh and he's surviving on not
much sleep because remember he wins the
Iowa caucuses then he has to fly landing
in New York City at 3:30 in the morning
appear in court the next day through the
afternoon then fly back to New Hampshire
do a rally then fly back to New York to
appear in court in the morning I mean
he's 77 years old but he's he he he's
got the stamina of a 26y old friends way
back like what were you guys friends in
business or were you just friends uh I I
met him in 1979 when I recruited he and
his father for the finance chairman for
to be members of the finance committee
for Ronald Reagan's campaign for
president of the United States in New
York state that's how we met and they
both joined Regan's Finance they both Jo
raised substantial money for us was that
Don's first uh like for into politics uh
you know if you're a New York City
developer you're always in politics and
you and you cover both sides remember
the city's dominated by democrats and
Democrats control stuff like permitting
and Zoning so Donald was was was
friendly with all politicians of both
parties uh it was uh the the first
person in the country really to suggest
that Trump should run for president was
Richard Nixon Nixon's in Exile he is a
friend of George Stein brener who owns
the New York Yankees uh he and Trump
meet in Stein Brenner's body
Nixon knows I'd done some work for Trump
trump knows I'm close to Nixon Nixon
calls me the next day well I met your
man said sir this guy could go all the
way I'm saying you're saying he should
run for govern no no no I said all the
way and then there's a famous letter
which Nixon and handwrites to Trump
telling him he should run for president
the New York Times has what year was it
it's had to be 80s around 89 well
there's that uh 87 it like he was on
Oprah or something and he it's ask he
was going to run for president yes he
and you know what he says probably not
probably not unless things got so bad
that I had no choice yeah and we came to
that point I didn't know we were at that
point in 2012 I just thought stuff was a
little crazy but I didn't realize like
that the liberal economic order was
morphing into this new world order that
it had been planned for 30 or 40 years
and I had no idea well in retrospect we
still weren't quite at that moment so in
2012 he I think reluctantly endorsed
Mitt Romney he almost immediately had
sellers re remorse every time there's a
debate he would call me and say what's
wrong with this guy he's got no Instinct
for the jugular and then it was New
Year's Day of 20 13 when he said I've
applied to the to the patent and
trademark office to trademark the phrase
make America great again what year was
that 2013 yeah so he he I knew he was
running in 2016 uh Michael Moore tried
claiming that Trump didn't actually want
to run it was did you see that
documentary he did Fahrenheit 119 and
he's saying something was it Gwen
Stefani or something like this like
someone got a bigger NBC contract than
Trump and Trump was offended because
he's the he's the big shot he's The
Apprentice so he decided he would run
for president just to bolster his uh his
his recognition and then try and get a
better contract but then he accidentally
won it's the most insane thing Michael
Moore what were you thinking the dude
you say he trademarked Maga right years
in advance everybody knew this was
coming but look he talked about running
uh in
200000 he he talked he talked about
running in 1988 first time he went to
Port Smith New Hampshire where he was
two nights ago to speak to the Portsmith
Chamber of Commerce the first time there
was speculation about him running he was
nowhere near ready I don't think he was
that he wasn't that serious about it but
he wanted to kind of test the waters
then he looked at it again in 2000 Jesse
ventur
who had had become governor of Minnesota
uh had been obviously a very famous
wrestler urged him to do it Ross perau
his fellow billionaire urged him to do
it uh he still wasn't ready I think he
toyed with it but he he never ran by the
way he won the Reform Party primaries in
Michigan and California weeks after
withdrawing as a candidate and saying
definitively he would not be a candidate
uh he looked at it seriously again in
2012 the reporters all insisted he's
just burnishing the brand he's never
really going to run this is all great PR
genius I think he was always seriously
interested he was waiting for the right
time 2016 turned out to be the right
time and isn't that better I mean if
what he said on Oprah he's thinking
about it if he needed to run then he
would I think that's much more of the
like servant leadership that people
don't actually give Trump credit for it
wasn't about his ego it was about saying
I can actually change something I can
make a difference here it's cost him
hundreds of millions of dollars he was
universally he was
liked now he's a polarizing figure it's
C him millions in legal fees he's put up
with an enormous amount of vituperation
attacks on his family he's doing it
because he loves the country he's not
doing it because he needs more Name ID
the Trump the first Trump term was a
magical time despite the cinder blocks
they duct taped to Trump's feet it was
it was a great time I mean e
economically especially and of course
2020 things got Mony but I don't blame
Trump for that and then you have the
Biden years and these past uh uh 3 and a
half years have been miserable it's just
been it's it's been atrophy the 2016 to
20 was like agitation it was like you
can use it it you can use agitation to
grow muscle you know you agitate the
system to cause a growth response or you
cause an immune respon you cause a lot
of things with agitation but lately it's
just felt like it's falling apart that's
wasting away like that there's
no I don't know it's it's a very
hopeless time especially if you're a
young voter in this country which is why
once again he's exactly the right man at
the right time people who don't know him
just have no idea how tough this guy is
he's he's extraordinarily tough I worked
for Richard Nixon very tough guy
greatest political comeback in American
political history I work for Senator Bob
Dole another tough guy he got hit by a
shell in World War II they told me never
walk again never have the use of I he
nursed himself back to health to a
senate career in to win a presidential
nomination one of the greatest men of
the 20th century those guys were very
very tough guys Trump is tougher than
either one of them well you got into
politics to during the Nixon era uh yes
that was my first boss what got you
involved in it well actually I was
originally a Goldwater Zealot when I was
12 years old uh I read the book
conscience of a conservative uh and I
realized that I was an anti-communist
who believed in personal freedom and
small government and a strong National
Defense uh and privacy uh and then when
Goldwater lost I was crushed because I
was 12 years old what the hell do you
know when you're 12 years old uh and
then I I started reading about Nixon and
I concluded that he had been robbed of
the 1960 election so I wrote him a
letter when he was in Exile uh
practicing law on Wall Street and I told
him if he ever ran again I wanted to
sign up uh and they kept my letter on
file for two years and then when he
decided to make a comeback uh I got a
call asked me if I wanted to come in and
you for a job you were in your 20s they
a little surprised when I was 16 years
old yeah at that point you got the job
as a gopher yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net